it's a detective story it's very hard to
find out the real information about this
I had to go and get it had 21 I wanted
to experience what was happening whether
or not that was going to be a film or
something I was just going to report
back to people in my area so I think we
just we followed the geography matt
sanchez the co-creator and editor and I
just basically had to go through a
process of remembering every step of the
way and that became the narration that
became the discovery process I also
needed to be funny because the people i
mean we took our sense of humor from the
folks in film obviously have this
incredible gallus that's a humor that
I'd met Josh when he did the first
segment over two years ago and he wasn't
quite sure if it was going to become a
full-length feature at that time and I
was pretty active in the community
because when I heard about this I was
stunned at the thought of it in our
backyards and such a pristine clean
environment in upstate New York and when
he showed me a rough assembly habibi
immediately became fully committed on
every level it's hard to separate
filming from editing from talking about
this it seems to happen every single day
we're out so when does you know when to
stop Sundance deadline sunny I saw
Sundance I mean right